um so me talk sixty minutes let's see we
can do it I've got a ridiculous number
of slides there's a lot of stuff to
cover in here and it's mostly code but
I'll start gently I'll break you in
gently let the caffeine kick in a bit
more so I share so the title of this
talk is not a particularly sexy title
it's a it's a depending on what your
background is it's either an incredibly
obscure reference or a comfortable
computer science reference to this book
here structure and interpretation of
computer programs by Abelson and Sussman
published originally in the seventies
based on scheme all kinds of wonderful
stuff in here but partly it was the
title because I think for me not enough
people focus on when we're talking about
unit tests they don't refocus on the
structure they just say we have unit
tests and they're and what about the
interpretation the idea is to quote them
programs must be written for people to
read it only incidentally for machines
to execute there is this idea of people
are your target audience there for
interpretation and how do people read
tests well honestly looking at some
tests in production you kind of think
people read tests as rarely as possible
because because honestly it's just like
you know what I have no idea what this
does I hope it never fails because if it
fails I will have to do one of two
things one of which is you know put
ignore on it or comment it out or yeah
and come back to it later you know that
one yeah we'll just take it we'll come
back and fix that one later so you know
it was a sort of amazing backlog of dead
tests yeah okay so there's that approach
or I'm going to spend a lot of time
trying to understand it and so there's
this idea of admitting that
interpretation and the communication are
first-class citizens when you're writing
a test and here's our target audience
jeromy's are us in German I wrote kind
of the book is about 10 years ago
a quite a hefty book just over 10 years
ago yeah xunit test patterns
it's about unit tests it's loads of
different techniques practices ideas so
on it's about a thousand pages so if you
have the hard copy you can actually use
it as a weapon okay you can add this is
you can convince your colleagues of the
rightness of your true path for testing
by actually just beating them around you
don't need you don't need all that
nonsense of having to have a reasonable
rational argument to put to them yeah
however I managed to get for 497 things
every programmer should know I managed
to get gerald down to two pages which
are thoughts you know yeah good a good
reduction right test for people there
you go that's your target audience who
should be writing the test sport for the
person trying to understand your code
now what is interesting here is what he
says for the person trying to understand
your code he means your production code
you don't write tests for the people
trying to understand your tests your
write tests for people trying to
understand the code that is being tested
and that's a there's a very subtle
distinction there but a very important
one which means that you need to be very
careful with certain habits that you may
have it turns out that test code and
production code are in many ways quite
different they serve different purposes
and they also have different habits some
of the practices that you may think are
sort of sacred and and hallowed for
production code don't necessarily apply
to test code but it also means and this
is quite important where you need to
avoid certain refactorings if I am
trying to understand the code that is
being executed one of the things I
should not do is factor out the
duplicate code across the test that
actually invokes the thing that I am
trying to execute I have seen that in
production or in tests and and and the
this group did such a good refactoring
that when you looked at their tests you
had absolutely no idea what was going on
you had we set up the test and then we
run the tests and then we do the cleaner
and it's okay so well yes but what are
you actually testing all that code is
down that's over here we factored it out
because it was
p-ting is like yes that's the bit I need
to see the bit that's repeating that
should be in the test because this is
documentation show me how it's used
otherwise you end up looking at it from
another point of view
imagine you're reading a manual or
imagine you're reading a book and it's
showing you how to use how to work with
something or yeah the classic getting
started stuff you downloading a
framework you want that getting started
page it's no good if the getting started
page says this is like the code we saw
above go back up you want to see it
there and then that's what you're
reading at the moment so you need to
understand how people read um we also
need to look at language Alistair Coburn
made this observation 2008 actually here
is building very many people say TDD
when they really mean I have good unit
tests I have guts often we substitute
one term for another perhaps because
we're not aware and perhaps because
naming is hard
perhaps because a term becomes really
sexy you know it's just like yeah we're
doing test-driven development as opposed
to we're kind of doing more unit tests
than we used to
yeah so you're gonna put that on your CV
you're gonna say yes the strategy we
employed at this company was to do your
unit test than we were doing before it
doesn't say we use TDD there you go it's
buzzword friendly actually that said
more tests than before mttb you know
let's try that one so the problem is we
end up repurposing a term or choosing an
adjacent term and it changes its meaning
so a lot of people they're not doing TDD
and that's absolutely fine what they're
doing is good unit test better unit
tests and they were doing before and
that's great and so it's this idea I
love this idea guts so I've been very
keen on this to good unit test guts and
if you happen to be a German speaker I
strongly recommend this because you can
now go around saying yeah how do you
want your test I wanted to be good
because you don't bad test do you yeah I
don't left I I want good tests okay so
this is really simple you can make a
very strong case for it so let's start
off with this
idea of you test so a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away I used to write for
the register technical stuff I focused
on units a unit test is a test of
behavior whose success or failure is
wholly determined by the correctness of
the test and the correctness of the unit
under test in other words if you test
passes is because of the test code and
the thing that you're testing if it
fails it's because of the test code and
the thing that you're testing us all
surely that's obvious and not so much
because there are things and reasons
that our tests may fail that have
nothing to do with correctness of code
so if we imagine our code here's the
stuff here is the call I'm going to be
very generous and optimistic look how
much is the unit testable the original
diagram had it as a kind of like a tiny
thing that was kind of like you know
proportionately like the Earth's core or
something it's like no now I thought you
know I got a going to conference being
positive so this is all the stuff that
is unit testable awesome in other words
it has no external dependencies this is
the key point that's sometimes what you
have here is if this code works it works
because of what you can see now there
are obviously certain Givens basic
Givens the world works ok that's a basic
given if you have a hardware bug then
your problem is not your unit tests if
your virtual machine is completely
screwed up then the problem is not your
unit tests ok but we're going to say
given that the platform on which you're
working is as expected
then all I am doing and it's under my
control
all I am doing is I am testing stuff and
like a hack and have confidence that
when it fails it shows a failure and
when it passes that I have demonstrated
something I may not necessarily be able
to demonstrate true correctness but what
I've done is I've actually said yeah I
can have confidence that this does
pretty much what I asked it to then you
have the code that is necessarily not
unit testable and this is a quite an
important thing because sometimes people
mistakenly equate unit tests with good
itself in other words it's a pure thing
and so it's like
thing that is not a unit test is and is
a test it doesn't necessarily it's not
bad there is a part of your codebase
that actually has to touch things that
it cannot control if you are touching
the file system you do not control the
file system if you think you do that's a
very sweet view but you don't you merely
influence it okay
you influence the network these are all
things that you can have some say in but
actually you don't control it okay so
this other things may happen and
necessarily your code needs to interact
with this stuff otherwise you've
probably got a fairly dull program or
it's a functional program base a
functional code base which is probably
quite dull actually so there is this
idea there is a bit that actually has to
touch the real world that bit cannot be
unit tested and every now and then I get
something coming up oh yeah but it's
really clever we mocked the file system
yeah well I mock your approach because
you haven't actually tested your code
against the file system you've tested
your code against the idea of a file
system that's the bit in the middle
we've done that that's where you should
already be now this is good these are
the two categories you want you are lots
of unit testable stuff stuff that has
functional qualities or a simple object
model you can just look at it go yes I
can test this this has this known effect
and then there are these other things
where the test may fail not because the
test is wrong not because the code is
wrong but because the real world is
wrong okay something happened out there
and we're not quite sure what somebody
changed the database password or
whatever and then there's the third
category this is the one you don't want
should be unit testable but isn't oops
now it turns out that this is often
quite large and code bases yeah but what
you're getting here if we use this
definition and of course there are lots
of definitions of what is a unit test
I'm not saying this is what the one true
definition but many years ago I came to
the conclusion that there are certain
terms like unit tests like software
architecture that have originated in
multiple from multiple different
locations and those that have a single
origin point of origin and so there
isn't one true definition we can go back
to but what we can distinguishes between
definitions that are more and less or
less useful I like this definition
because it teaches me something about
Mike
if I'm looking at something and I cannot
unit test it then I have a question it's
teaching me about the architecture
should this be unit testable and it's
simply a piece of accidental complexity
an accidental piece of coupling that we
have got that we probably shouldn't have
or actually is this necessarily not unit
testable
okay distinguish between those two
categories and shrink that bit in the
sandwich so there is this other aspect
to unit testing catch by table Golding
rather nicely in the best software
magazine a number of years ago and this
is something I experienced quite a lot
when when you get into a conversation
about unit tests it's it it doesn't take
very long before you find yourself
talking about frameworks and mocking
frameworks in this framework and that
framework and it's so oh hold back and I
run TDD training for people I run
workshops and one of the most common
questions is which framework are you
going to use and part of me just says
which do you want you know but the other
part is honestly it doesn't matter this
is not about learning how to use a
testing framework although clearly that
is within your reach and is something
you should do
the real challenge is do you know how to
drive it mostly people are as it were
consumers of frameworks rather than
people who drive the framework and say I
want to write this test how do I do this
they say this is possible it's on the
demo page I'm going to copy/paste it
which explains most mock object testing
the disaster that is the majority of
mock object testing a good idea done
badly and the program will be made unit
testing more about applying an
exercising frameworks because naturally
you sit there thinking I am programmer I
know how to code I know how to use a
framework so therefore if I learned how
to do this then it's a matter simply of
using a framework I've done that before
I had essentially reduced my concept of
unit testing to the basic mechanics of
exercising new test frameworks to verify
the behavior of my classes my mindset
happy thinking far too narrowly about
what it meant to write good unit tests
that phrase again it's this idea of the
good unit test
is often the basic idea is often
independent of the framework and the
framework allows you to realize
something in a particular way but often
people use frameworks relatively poorly
they have thought about it in terms of
its pro Cabul area of assertions and the
other mechanics within it rather than
saying actually what am I trying to do
here what am I trying to say if this is
an act of communication to whom am i
communicating and what is it that I
think is important to emphasize so I'm
going to pick an example which starts
like so there's a couple of examples
that I tend to use because they often
illustrate they're surprisingly deep
when you scratch the surface so I got to
pick a very simple example leap you a
classification I pick leap your
classification because it turns out that
this is something that people generally
get wrong ask yourself for for a leap
year with the Gregorian calendar
assuming a bank data the proleptic
Gregorian calendar when is a year a leap
year don't worry about all the weird
stuff like when did a country adopt the
Gregorian calendar that that you know if
you john ski is here in the third row if
you want to have a chat with him
afterwards about that you'll be there
all day you know the ski to pedia is
quite comprehensive on this you know and
this is actually there's a whole load of
absolutely fascinating ones they asked
me and John about Sweden any Swedes in
the audience oh yeah you guys have the
most original approach to try to adopt
the Gregorian calendar absolutely
fascinating you know it's it was a it
was a precursor of brexit you know it's
just like disastrous and absolutely
pointless so but it didn't have any
consequences so nice dry run there
though so we're going to simplify that
so ask yourself when is a year a leap
year it's a very simple thing but it
helps emphasize and by the way my this
is a sort of panic data but based on
years and years of asking people amongst
developers I would say approximately
between five and ten percent of
developers know this okay is a kind of
geeky fad amongst the general population
is probably down to about 1% okay but
five to 10% of programs know the rule so
here's a really interesting one the
challenge here is is not actually to
write the right code the challenge here
is to create a test that communicates
what a leap year is now for many people
their there their goal is I wish to
create code I wish to create a test that
shows that this is correct
the real challenge when you come to a
piece of code is not does this work I
very rarely look at a piece of code and
ask what does this work I want to know
what does it mean by it works how does
this work what is it trying to do the
question does it work until I've
understood what I'm expecting is almost
irrelevant what tests are green it must
work then you look at the unit test I
thought I have no idea what it means for
it to work that is the greater challenge
the meaning so we might go ahead and you
know let's warm up a little bit and so
you know I'm gonna write myself a little
to use then unit I'm gonna write myself
a little c-sharp method here I'm gonna
go yes I'm gonna write a test and what
should I call it test that seems good
you're right you're right I can do
better I haven't is leap year
method is essentially a function it's a
pure function it might exist within a
static class and that's it it's a it's a
that's all it's doing yes okay well yeah
you don't really tell me much and then
people go ah there you go
that one honestly this is guaranteed to
currently who once in every test suite
test that something is correct
is okay works there's a whole load of
suffixes that people use unless you are
prepared to write unless you're ever
prepared to say the opposite test that
this doesn't work and that by the way
there are cases that that for which that
makes sense but those are more or more
on the edge there's that those are
exceptional cases ruff rather you know
bug for bug compatibility for example
and this is this is noise this word
doesn't these words don't actually add
anything I'm expecting that so then
somebody says break up your tests and
people do what they normally do when
they break up long methods and they have
you know this is this is one of those
things about giving out terrible advice
when the worst piece of advice you can
ever give somebody is you should make
that method smaller or break that method
up because they will do so okay
what you're missing is that's not good
that's not constructive advice it's
observation advice it's when I look at
something in her short methods that is
that tells me something but to tell
somebody make them shorter or chop it up
they will do this you know this is I'm
not kidding about this one is you know I
see this quite often I also see ordinary
methods broken up like this yeah it's
yeah the one two three really doesn't
help so test 1 test 2 that's not very
helpful so we can perhaps do it haha now
we're getting somewhere
let's let's divide the world into leap
years and normally peers or common years
and so we think we think we found it
we've partitioned we've partitioned the
domain that we're dealing with into two
there are leap years and there are
normally peers oh this should be not
easy great so let's have a look at some
examples so it's true that 2016 is a
leap year and 2000s leap year okay so
then somebody says well no we should
break these out more and partly they
will also realize if you look here
there's a slight problem it turns out
that there are not two kinds of year in
the system of classification there are
four kinds of year it turns out that
2000 is a leap year for quite different
reasons than 2016 so it turns out that
the there is a there there is a the rule
involves years divisible by four 100 and
400 it turns out there are four
categories because you may need to
remember them not divisible by four so
there's four kinds of year not two and
that's not visible here
that's just incidental data that's not
obvious so in an attempt to make this
more explicit many people end up writing
this now there are some improvements
here that we can make the first one is
to recognize that obviously that word
test is not doing any work for us okay
if you have it if you have a framework
so for example if you're using something
like pythons unit test it expects test2
be the first of all letters if you're a
requirement if your framework requires
it then you have no choice but to use it
that's fine but if your framework
doesn't require it and you
already have the word test plastered all
over it I mean honestly it doesn't get
much clearer than having a huge great
attribute there it's just that honesty
let's let's just assume that that's a
given
so we can simplify it there okay that's
fine
and now we're getting a slightly
stronger statement 2016 is a leap year
2000 is leap year 2018 is not a leap
year 1900 is not a leap year Oh bye this
is good however I still can't see why
they're different but there's another
thing going on here is that these are
just incidental because if I just
changed the years oh yes by the way I
should also this is a point consider
changing your naming convention of your
own using a snake case I'm not
suggesting that if you're using a camel
case that you should not use camel case
in your production code but this is not
regular production code you never
actually call this so try to think of it
more like a sentence which is exactly
what this is whereas many methods are
named after verb phrases imperatives and
classes are named after noun phrases for
example so there is this idea of using
the appropriate style of language and so
therefore you will find that sentences
are generally longer than phrases so
give them a little bit of space it turns
out that our ability to read even if you
can read German your ability to read
letters that are matched up together in
a traffic jam is actually severely
compromised after about 30 characters
okay and these names often go a lot
longer than that
so I guess and there's no there's a
concept there's a concept here sometimes
people wonder about far trends what's
called far transfer does your ability to
read alphabets such as the tie tie
system of writing transfer into being
able to read this you know so you can
match all the letter together it turns
out the answer is no so give them a
little bit of space now let's focus on
those and then I'm gonna make a change
now the problem here is a Gazoo that
there's no difference between what I was
just testing what I've just tested now
because it turns out 2020 is a leap year
for the same reasons that 2016 is a leap
year 2019 is not a leap year for the
same reasons that 2018 is not a leap
year but notice how much of that is in
the
I'm giving you here but none of it is
visible there all this stuff I'm saying
should be there so there we go this is a
better statement yes divisible by four
elite years news about 400 elite news
yes not divisible by four not need peers
used to this by 100 on Olivia's now
there is an interesting one here before
we address the names about sequence this
is reading you're reading things now
often people will latch on to the
divisible by four thing as the first
thing that's the first thing people
think about with leap years and that's
natural but the thing to remember is the
order in which you write the test is not
necessarily the order that in which
people would like to read them so always
remember that when you're coming back
because often I see tests I see the test
Suites with sort of a almost random
order they don't tell a story they are
written in the order that the developer
thought of them in which is you know not
unreasonable but there's a notion there
go back and look at them are they
telling a story if something is
different for an empty case than it is
for a null case then put those two
together don't put one at the end and
there and the other at the beginning
because these are things that people
would probably think of at the same time
show that null and empty are different
or the same
side-by-side because people would expect
to see them don't start with the most
complex case and end with the simplest
case you know if you've got a repository
what's your initial state well I'm
hoping it's empty
what stunts that's where the story
starts what's your next thing oh we add
loads of items to it no and one thing
just one and then somebody says but in
production we need to hold millions yeah
I know but if you can't hold one the
other ninety nine hundred and ninety
nine thousand or whatever irrelevant so
therefore just move to the next step
tell the stories show the behaviors try
and interact with it so this is actually
not really the story that I want to tell
the story I want to tell is I'm gonna
start with years not to visible by four
in this particular case what is the what
is the most common kind of year
statistically the most common kind of
year is not a leap year okay spaz
seventy five percent of them this year
is a good example pick a year at random
it's probably not a leap so start with
this is Italy pure false now
fact you can even hard-code it return
false okay don't don't say I told you
this but yeah but honestly that code
will be right about 75% of the time
which is better than some code I've seen
so that is certainly an improvement now
notice what we're doing here is we've
started with in this case find where
your story starts is an empty thing okay
is it a simply constructed thing is it a
large classification a simple default
state wherever it is start there and
then move in slowly progressively
divisible by four differ by 100
divisible by 400 you're narrowing in
you're making it much more specific
however what we realize is that there is
a contradiction years divisible by four
elite peers use divisible by 100 are not
leap years these two statements cannot
simul taneous li be true okay there is a
there's an arithmetic contradiction you
mister visible by 100 it is divisible by
four so since kind of Schrodinger state
okay yes and no it isn't leap this
teaches us that there is something else
about how we partition and how we name
these things is that your test cases
should have mutually exclusive names so
you look at it and it characterizes the
behavior whereas sometimes when they
have overlapping names you now need to
read all the tests in order to
understand the overlap you should make
your test as local as possible okay so
what we actually discovers it doesn't
feel in the slide so years not divisible
by four and not leap years use divisible
by four but not by $100 Pierce aha now
we've learnt the rule where yes it was
by 100 but not by 400 Arnold he is years
- by 400 olivia's now this is very much
the leap year rule for the proleptic
Gregorian calendar okay but we're not
done there are other techniques that
have this kind of death my preference is
for this style which I'll mention is a
propositional style in other words the
names of proposition you may have come
across royal sheriff's approach which is
name the method name the input name the
response yeah again if you look the same
information is there it's just
structured differently I have a
preference for one but I don't you know
this is absolutely fine because it gets
us away from the test is
here problems you've actually broken
down the characteristics that you're
interested in as it were the before the
action and the after so when it comes to
propositions and logic and this is this
is the whole thing testing is very much
based on trying to figure out what
you're trying to say and to express it
this is hard and so in the world of ones
and zeroes it turns out logic is
surprisingly useful this is a book that
taught me a lot of logic and you can
tell either how old it is or how old I
am because people just don't produce
stuff with typefaces like that anymore
there's a sort of a glorious retro feel
to it but the idea of a proposition
propositions are vehicles for stating
how things are all might be so we are
saying something about the world only
indicative sentences which makes sense
to think of as being true or being false
are capable expressing propositions so
you're making concrete statements okay
so we've got that now there's an
implementation it passes it's green this
is why I prefer the propositional style
because it tells you what you have in
other words when the tests pass it's a
description of the capabilities the
properties the behaviors or whatever
that you have here is a manifest of what
the code does now let's replace it with
a naive implementation the Julian leap
year just modulo four and suddenly we
get a red so in other words what's
interesting is we now know exactly what
is wrong it is the contradiction is the
negation of the proposition what we know
is that our code for years divisible by
100 but not by 400 and not even well
that's not true clearly years divisible
by 100 but not by 400 are leap years you
now know it's the exact opposite of what
it says so therefore you know what you
don't have so I tend to favor this
naming approach because it works
directly both as a result in other words
you see it as this is what happened to
your test and as a name in the code
whereas conventions like should don't
really do that
okay so this is this idea that prices
Steve Freeman made this observation
number of years ago are your tests
really
development to drive to ballot they must
do more than just test that Co performs
its required functionality they must
clearly Express that required
functionality to the reader it's not
enough to just poke it and see and poke
it yeah it's green it's guys like
communicate there's an active
communication here so clear
specifications of the required
functionality now we can take this a
little bit further this is where it gets
a bit more interesting so one of the
things you'll discover is you end up
with long sentences long sentences with
lots of commonality what do you do with
commonality factor it out so here I'm
going to nest the tests instead a number
of testing frameworks will allow you to
do this so this has been available an
end unit for a long time so in terms of
nesting your namespaces I can do it
classes properly with J unit 5 and I can
just about kick J unit forward you're
doing the right thing but different this
idea of have a hierarchy and so I've got
this idea of a leap year spec and what
I've now done is I've grouped by outcome
a year as a leap year a year is not a
leap year this is how people are
thinking in terms of a classifier then
I'm going to show you the outcomes a
year is a leap year if it is divisible
by 4 but not 100 a year's a leap you
have this divisible by 400 it's not a
leap year and so on so this use of
hierarchy is really important first of
all it makes your name shorter but it
actually groups things so that people
it's almost as though I'm creating a
PowerPoint presentation and showing you
here is how all these relate rather than
some long rambling sentences yeah don't
worry about making them long initially
but then look for the fact it's very
unlikely you're going to end up with
lots of long names and they will have no
commonality they normally have repeating
parts what is that repeating part the
reader probably wants to know because
it's probably part of the model of how
to think about the code so yeah we have
yeah so we have some examples here now
let's just focus on the test data
examples that we're using I've happened
to have chosen 2018 and 1900 for these
two I could have chosen anything but
there is a difference so 42 and 100 work
just fine
now this is interesting because many
people when I run this as a as a
workshop example many people will
choose not to use years they use numbers
like 1 or 3 or stuff like that now
whilst technically these are not
incorrect as an act of communication
they're not particularly good because
although 42 technically is a year in
this system if you're a if you're a
developer of a certain background you
look at the number 42 and you think oh
yeah go check out galaxy you don't
immediately look at it and go yeah
whereas if I write two zero one eight
two zero one nine it's it's almost
impossible to not think of that number
as a year it's not merely an integer you
have a set of associations now if this
is an act of communication what you're
going to do is work with the reader work
with their associations make it look
like a year use examples from their
domain if you're talking about people's
names it turns out that foo and bar are
terrible names to give to your children
but ok do not do this to your children
and do not do it in tests ok so there is
this idea of really work the data make
things obvious let the data speak very
strongly if you're dealing with names as
well by the way in terms of names watch
out for ambiguous names ok Stuart is
that is that a last name or a first name
yes so therefore you're not letting your
data speak for you ok there's a bunch of
names that you would really want
somebody to read that and already have a
very strong grass without having to sit
there and look at signatures use the
data it's part of it's part of the story
now another way of getting around this
is to have multiple things and therefore
once you have multiples you can you know
choose the counterintuitive the non non
year looking examples towards the end
that's fine but we many test frameworks
will now allow you allow you to fact
this stuff out so so find out if you're
testing prepare your test framework does
this find out and if it doesn't find out
if your testing framework has the
ability to support extensions and and so
on so there's this idea of here I've
kept this quite declarative I like a
good piece of declarative coding so
therefore I've got this factored out
here are all the cases this is the code
that's being executed and this is the
proposition that has been made there are
three parts to the story the data that
drives at the example and the actual
a proposition in this particular case I
can also use values which is simple but
you get eat the test is executed in four
cases okay so we've got this we can
generalize this over here we can use a
range all kinds of stuff so it now
becomes quite expressive but still
people sometimes try to over over
program it so occasionally I get this
ones yeah yeah but I want to test all
the years and then you end up with this
a year is either a leap year or not
range 1 to 10,000 I admire your tenacity
but what's this that what does this test
look like you know what is it going to
look like do not do yeah I have to put
this sometimes and slides for those
non-obvious progressions people look at
the slides and right there you go that's
intuitive and you look at that oh that's
really messy I tell you what I'll factor
that out and then you realize you've
just reinvented the implementation so
the point here is John yes I'm yes I am
absolutely happy to say but also I want
to build up to that in other words I say
here is what it should do and let me do
this exhaustively I would tend to treat
the exhaustive test as a different
category so that they can actually be
they might be long-running but their
goal is different there but what you're
doing is say now we have console dyou
what the story is now we have some
confidence in it let's just do this
exhaustively yeah and it's at that point
where some in some cases you might want
to do things that are random in other
cases you might want to have an
alternative source of the same value
perhaps it's less efficient perhaps it's
a library that's being replaced but the
idea is that that's not my first port of
call that's kind of like and now I
believe this is all good let's let's
turn all the dials up to 11 or 10,000
okay so we also need to deal with this
Tolstoy was a programmer it turns out
opening sentence of Anna Karenina the
only sentence of Anna Karenina I will
confess to reading have read all happy
families are like each unhappy family is
unhappy in its own way you need to deal
with stuff that is
exceptional and unsupported now here I'm
going to be arbitrary I'm going to say
look in the domain of proleptic the
proleptic calendar Gregorian calendar
I'm going to say I'm just not going to
support year 0 in other words now I'm
making stipulations about the
implementation I'm basically saying this
is not supported doesn't mean it's
necessarily wrong but you know it's not
supported a class a year is not
supported if it is zero and so it throws
an argument exception when we do that as
a side note if you're doing if you're
doing any unit don't use throws use
catch because throws really is exactly
what it says it if you throw an
exception that is derived from the
exception that is stated then it fails
that is very rarely how you ever ever
want to use an exception exceptions in
our languages are based on base classes
so therefore show me the usage the usage
is catch the usage is not catch it and
then check it's exactly the same type
and we can generalize that it is 0 if it
is negative and I can do that
interestingly I would not merge these
two some people will some people won't
this is very subjective the reason I do
this is because 0 is secure and
interesting when it comes to talking
about calendars and the answer does does
the calendar have a Year Zero or not to
which the answer is yes you haven't told
me which calendar you're using this is a
far more fascinating or boring
conversation than you would believe and
to the point that once when getting a
group to do this exercise they argued
for 10 minutes about whether or not
there was a Year Zero and I kind of
ended that discussion with and now you
know why I keep it separate because what
you're doing is your tests sometimes
exist not for completeness but for
emphasis it is as if you were writing a
document and you said I read it I want
you to notice that I've noticed this
we've taken account of this I will
single it out I'll put it in bold I'll
give its own section or whatever it is
use the same technique here I'm saying I
want you to know we've covered 0 we're
good ok whatever we think of it it's
here we're done and there's a there's a
complement to that it's already implied
by the rest but it's sometimes worth you
start realizing balancing out when is a
year supported I'm going to go gear to
int max value in the
case I will use values not range by the
way it takes a range will execute all
the way from one to two billion and that
is certainly quite exhaustive but it
won't really prove very much so I'm just
gonna choose examples at each end of the
range just say look just in case you
were wondering yes we're good okay so
let's talk about stacks stacks of
objects I'm going to do this example we
will start off with a very simple view
what is the stack its its stack is the
most overused abstract data type in
computer science is the short answer
and so therefore I feel tradition-bound
to do this let's talk about things you
can do with the stat you can create one
you can push to it you can pop from it
you can find its depth you can ask for
its top
so ADT's very much this is we don't care
about the implementation this day the
whole idea of abstract data types
Barbara Liskov did a lot of work on this
one of the things she received cheering
award for so this is from 1974 an
abstract data type defines a class
master public which is completely
characterized by the operations
available on those objects now the
reason I put this here is to really
emphasize something no we're not going
to test the private section no you do
not want to do that treat that always as
your default opening position if you
feel that you want to test the private
section of something then there's
probably something else going on so I
this is a kind of a 99.9% rule or a 99
percent rule depending on if you're
having an easy day in other words you
should just assume that you probably
don't want to do this there are cases
where you might but just treat them with
suspicion so therefore we should be able
to characterize this behavior completely
okay so this allows me to use them
upside down A's and back-to-front is for
all types T there exists a stack such
that and got all these various
operations so we've described it as a
sort of an abstract data type using a
Cartesian product signatures excellent
but that's not their really gonna work
in most code so I'm gonna do this one in
C++ nothing particularly weird
here yeah just got a little bit of extra
noise if you're not used to C++ I'll
probably change a couple of bits of the
signature as we go through I'm making
the pure I'm making the pot I'm keeping
pop simple a lot of people assume that
pop returns a value for a number of
reasons that's not always the best
design if you've done any functional
programming you'll know that's not the
best design if you haven't done
functional programming you may also know
that it's not the best design but but
here we're going to we're going to do
that and so basically we can construct
it we can push pop we can ask for its
depth we get a size and unsigned
quantity Const merely indicates these
are pure queries and top gives me a tea
okay now I'm going to use the catch
framework and catch Frank was devout by
Phil Nash development support by Phil
Nash and it kind of builds on on on an
idea that I originally trialed in a a
testing framework called heathrow where
I just got sick to death of this whole
question about identify as I said I want
to use strings because in number in in
other frameworks I can do this about 10
years ago I created this idea this
approach for doing this in in C++ and in
C where I could just simply use strings
instead of their starting with the idea
that a test case must be a function or a
method that's the wrong place to start
just because that's how you implement in
some languages doesn't mean that's the
best place to start so III I went ahead
and did that Phil did a much better job
in terms of creating something that was
built from that and I and he supports it
we can do a little better than just it's
a bunch of test cases we can basically
say here I'm gonna tell you a story I'm
actually create a narrative here's a
test case is all about status now you
have different sections I'm going to
talk about the constructor I talked
about push the pot the death okay but we
had this conversation earlier on that
word test is a bit noisy the problem
here is what I've done is just repeated
the public interface and that in others
haven't really told you anything useful
and it turns out that how you think
about a class and you think about
instances of it is not by using
individual methods in this interface you
think about it in terms of proper usage
so if you if you follow that approach
you have a bit of a problem because and
this is something that I can do in C++
11 I can basically tell the compiler by
the way I'm not going to define the
default constructor I would like you to
generate it for me and I can actually
make that explicit so what I'm telling
you I'm telling the reader is by the way
the compiler is going to come up with a
default constructor here now think about
that from the testing point of view
that's a bit weird isn't it if I am
testing the individual functions why am
i testing a thing the compiler created I
obviously don't either you do need it
you absolutely need it but you need to
reframe how you're approaching the
problem you are not testing individual
methods that is not how you use objects
it's not how you test objects it's
actually not possible to do it so
sometimes people kind of say oh I'll
just use some slightly Security's
language and this is this is the classic
get out again
every test suite has loads of these can
be constructed can be pushed cat see I'm
using proper words Kevlar yeah I've got
sentences here can be popped has death
has a top yeah that's not true is it
because you can't pop an empty stack and
an empty stack has no top so you end up
revising that too can sometimes be
popped and sometimes has a top yeah the
force and precision of the language has
subtly got this is not how you want to
approach it either it's this very much
this propositional approach so Chris old
would observe trouble with full stack
developers you can't push them so they
thought that the phrase full stack
developer just deserves to be mocked
mercilessly if you are a full stack
developer take it off your CV come on
unless you're actually doing device
driver work and front-end work and all
the points in between you can't really
call yourself a full stack developer or
on there's a very strong case to be made
for firmware work as well ok so how are
we going to go about this we need a
better thinking model so let's pick on
given when that okay this gives us a
narrative you give us a simple story
given when then okay given an T stat so
the given when then tryptic allows us to
tell a story quite simply at any level
we can think of it as requirements on
the system as a whole we can structure
our user stories
but I can also make it about object
stories I can take it all the way in
it's the same model is it's recursive
it's Turtles all the way down given an
anti stack when an item is pushed then
it should not be empty we just talked
about strength of language I'm not a big
fan of if should helps you absolutely go
for it but honestly I think it's a
little bit like training wheels on a
bicycle is once you've got there take
them off sure it is is kind of not very
strong it kind of it's a it's a bit like
my like listen to my teenagers talk you
know if it's okay with you I think that
kind of maybe perhaps I should probably
yeah don't you think a little bit of up
talking you then get to the point
so this advice it turns out it's not
just Tolstoy who was a programmer
it turns out Strunk and white and the
classic Elements of Style had some great
advice for programmers look they were
testers make definite and make definite
assertions okay way before anybody
thought of the assert statement in the
1960s make definite surgeons avoid team
colorless hesitating non-committal
language by a sentence made stronger a
usually becomes shorter as brevity as a
byproduct of the figure excellent right
let's do that it must not be empty oh ok
either it is not empty yeah you'd have
to shout at the reader
it's just a statement about it but even
this is actually quite vague okay think
about it for a moment
you just put something into an empty
stack what can you say about it it's not
empty you know there are lots of non
empty States they are not all equivalent
it has a depth of 1 ah doesn't have a
depth of 2 or 3 or 4 if you're dealing
with int it turns out there are two
billion answers that are wrong
that are not empty there is only one
that is correct and it's that one and
actually there's a stronger statement
and the top item is the item that's
pushed that's the state that is the post
condition of that so then we try and
turn this into a name
yeah no way and we think wait a minute
Kevin talked about underscores earlier
on you're right I talked about in the
schools earlier on let's do that
okay honestly we can we can stretch it a
little bit put some spaces in we recover
our given win then then we realize you
don't although this is sometimes quite
useful in terms of nesting and so on you
don't necessarily need to do that there
is a shorter English sentence that says
the same thing an empty stack acquires
death by retaining your push item as
it's time you could but this is also
something else a lesson in not simply
that naming is hard but it turns out
there is a process for naming naming
start off with a sketch here's what I
think I know and they'll probably be a
lot longer or it may be too short and
then come back to it your test names are
not written or e they are not engraved
in stone they're one of the easiest
things to change because other code
doesn't depend on them so treat them as
a little bit of a journey as you
understand it more and more you
understand that what you're trying to
say you are learning quite literally
when you're writing tests you are
learning how to talk about the code that
you're testing the idea that you would
know immediately what you wanted to say
is optimistic so give yourself a bit of
slack you know you're gonna get it wrong
and you're learning a better way of
doing that just assume that that's the
case so in one of their most brilliantly
self-referential pieces of advice omit
needless words okay so now I can take
this I can take this a little more
seriously stack specification section an
empty stack acquires death by retaining
you're pushed itemizes top now this
begins you look a little bit like a spec
I'm gonna take a stack of strings I'm
gonna push NDC I'm gonna say I'm gonna
require that stack deaths is one the top
is NDC okay so we this kind of reads
quite nicely and I've got a bunch of
other sections here that's kind of get
rid of the noise a new stack is empty an
empty stack throws when career it's top
item and if you stare throws when pop
and so on okay now it's a couple of
other things here that are interesting
that when we when we look at the naming
when we look at the kind of the
structure that we've got there's
something else going on here for each
usage scenario the test describe the
context starting point or preconditions
that must be satisfied so back to
Jared's advice they illustrate how the
software is invoked they describe
expected results or post conditions
verified this is kind of a very standard
kind of rule of three in fact sometimes
people talk about is the three A's
arranged act assert but what is
interesting is this has been
rediscovered time and time again that
there's this kind of sort of three act
play that goes on so some people talk
about as given when then which is
identical its equivalent there is no
difference to that and then there's a
nice deep robes of deeper observation
just demonstrating there's actually you
don't have to know very much in computer
science there's only a handful of ideas
they just go by different names at
different times
Jason Gorman fun fact given when then
it's what we call a halt ripple which
Tony Hall the idea of a precondition a
piece of code and the post condition
that's on it this dates back to nineteen
sixty nine so it's not exactly new
although his syntax was slightly
different then if the assertion P is
true before initiation of program Q then
the assertion I'll be true on its
completion this is a really interesting
one because we're looking at from the
point of view of tests but this was also
the basis for a lot of formal reasoning
in code but it's the same story you've
got this three part thing here's this
thing here's the thing I'm doing to it
some transformation a calculation a
state modification whatever it is and
here is the world afterwards or what it
should be yeah and as there's our
there's our expectation so that's that's
you know that's that's quite nice but we
can relate it to some other things and
what I want to relate what I want to
relate this to is the idea of
understanding how does our stack behave
and it turns out there is a state model
here sometimes people try and understand
it through pre and post conditions it
turns out those are not quite adequate
four times I don't have enough time to
go into that but it turns out the
natural way of reasoning about this is
this you create new things you get an
empty one you push you get a non empty
you can call the depth top push and pop
on a non empty one when you pop a non
empty there's deaths of one then it goes
back to empty and you can only ask for
the depth you cannot you cannot top or
pop it so in other words we've got a
model here that shows you the life cycle
it turns out and let's map this let's
make our design decision we're going to
treat these as errors it turns out that
I can use exactly that to structure my
tests so there is a notion here people
often overlook the importance of having
a mental model of the state interactions
of their code and one of the things is
you can derive it from tests or you can
derive it from the knowledge of the
domain or the other way around you can
use your what hope you have a clear
model of what the state model is you can
actually use it to drive your tests it's
a it's a two-way street so what we've
got here a new stack is empty an empty
stack throws when career its top item
throws when pops it acquires a a non
empty stack becomes deeper by returning
pushed itemizes top so notice here we've
organized it and we've chosen to tell
the reader we are saying the thing i
want you to notice that's really
interesting is that there are new stacks
where there are things we can say about
them now let's generally talk about
empty stacks and let's talk about non
empty stacks and I've emphasized that as
the backbone of my test and hung
everything else off it so that's quite a
powerful way of quite a powerful way of
reasoning and exploring that but there's
a general lesson here given can be used
to group tests for operations with
respect to common initial state either
you arrived at that because you
understood the state model or you
arrived at that because you realize
there was repetition in your test names
and you thought the repetition well that
refers to the initial state or you're
arrived at it because you wanted to
factor out common fixture code and
common fixture code normally means we
are starting in the same place so given
so there's this idea I can group my test
cases according to the Givens the common
Givens
this is where we start given this then
let me tell you a story you can also do
it by winds when can be used to group
test by operation regardless of initial
state or outcome so for example what I
could do is I could group my tests
around the push and pop I could say when
you're pushing now on to an empty one
versus on to a non empty one and I was
there I've chosen to our
the operations now that's really good
for things like the standard model to
find if you are finding something in a
repository then it's either there or
it's not now perhaps you want to put
those test cases together you say yeah
when I'm searching when finding then
when it's there you get the reference to
it when it's not something else so that
can be useful as well now notice I am
offering you these I'm not saying one is
right or another you've got to determine
the story of the emphasis you want to
give to the reader and guess what you
can also group it by thence the outcome
in fact we did that that was the leap
year thing basically then it is a leap
year if but I chose to slight different
words a year is a leap year we've chosen
the outcome we're going to group by
common outcome so this is a very
powerful thing given when then it's not
just this simple thing for telling
stories it's much much much deeper it
connects to a question of how you want
to tell a story how you want to
emphasize things so who knew you could
squeeze so much from the stack so a
couple of things here we are all the
home straight that's a younger version
of me that was last week honestly after
that much then you know anyway this so
this is me Frank Bushman of Mitchie
Hennig a few years ago enjoying some
beer I I'm a little more moderate as a
drinker these days so there we go so
what am i talking about that's a queue
of bottles yes we've done stacks we're
going to talk about queues okay so oh
yes actually there's another reference
here as well I discovered that I'm in
this room basically the talk I'm doing
with Dylan Beatty is this afternoon it's
in this room and it turns out this is
the party room for this evening so I you
don't actually have to leave this room
okay I don't know if they'll have that
much beer I don't know if they're you
know but but there's only one way to
find out
that's been Pyrrhic about it so okay
let's do a ques what can I do with a cue
I can create one I can I can get its
length I can ask for its maximum
capacity I can put things in it and cue
and I can D cue them
okay so cue is very useful normally we
have some concept for a producer concept
of consumer and then we use some bland
word like cue or buffer or whatever in
between and it might be an improv thing
it might be into process
sockets accused pipes accuse all of this
stuff honestly if you want to if you
want to sex up your code a little bit in
your conversations it's a spacetime
decoupling that is way more interesting
there so why we've got a queue here
space-time decoupling okay because
that's what it is think about it for a
moment that's what you're doing is
you're decoupling either a rate of
production and a rate of consumption or
you are decoupling in time we know what
we want now but we're not in a position
to take advantage of it somebody will
get around to it later okay well we're
in the wrong place it needs to be over
there that's fine
so yeah space-time decoupling make
Europe make make the design language
more exciting things we can characterize
back cues and you understand why I put
in a buffer they can have a size
therefore their buffered bounded and
asynchronous things not to do make your
queues infinite this is a bad thing I
mean it works fine for demos and
prototypes but turns out that when
something goes wrong you run out of
memory it turns out you don't have
infinite storage you know I've looked on
eBay it's not available but as an aside
there are some interesting observations
I want to throw in it's always worth
understanding that in computer science
there's always you know zero one of many
one what is a queue of one it turns out
it's called the future well one side
it's called the future the other side is
called a promise it turns out that again
in computer science you don't have to
know very much if you know cues and
preconditions actions post conditions
you've done most of computer science oh
yes and if it's zero it turns out that
that's a Rondo what's called a
rendezvous it's a it's the default
channel modeling go for example it's a
very simple idea that you both have to
be there synchronous communication
however we're going to deal with n is
greater than zero so I've got the Java
code here I've got a capacity so we've
got some banner capacity there's the
length as the capacity we can ask it and
then I've got an in queue I I can acute
if it's full then that that will fail
but it's OK for it what fail is too
strong a word I'm going to basically say
it's not it's basically says I'm sorry
I'm full you know that's a well-defined
action there's no exception here
likewise DQ is soft we have an optional
of T that can be returned in other words
it's okay to DQ something that's not
there
you just get told
that's okay it's a question you can ask
it's not a correct position now I'm not
going to dive into the code for the cube
but what I want to do is say I don't
want to revisit that idea that sometimes
there is a relationship that is you
might say always just like the stack is
neck over yeah it's exactly like the
stack except for a bit that's not it
turns out the non emptiness is
philosophically far more interesting if
you're not empty then you can be non
full but you can also be full and the
behavior of a stack that a queue that is
full it's slightly different so there's
a hierarchical model here now why am i
emphasizing that well because you can do
that with the tests as well so using a
unit five and with there's an ant nest
is actually a ssin then what I've got
here is a slightly different story
here's the Q spec I've got a new Q an
empty queue in a non-empty queue a new
queue is empty and UQ preserves the
positive bounding capacity you can't you
cannot be created with non positive
bearing capacity an empty queue DQ's an
empty value so there's the fact that
it's okay to get that your option will
be empty an empty queue remains empty
when null is in queued that's an
interesting behavior if you try and put
null into it it'll be ignored but notice
how explicit this is I'm actually
showing you how to use the class this is
actually an instruction now it's not
many a set of tests so when they all
pass they're all great in other words
hey here all the features and they work
these are all available if any of them
are read then basically says this
feature is not available because of some
book now it gets more interesting down
here a non empty queue that is not full
becomes longer when non null value
include a non empty queue that is full
ignores further in cubed values okay so
now we have a very clear specification
behavior when you do concatenate all
these run-on sentences what you realize
is you do actually have a specification
these are propositions that can be true
or false
and we've taken advantage of as it were
you can't just look at the screen
sometimes you have to kind of step back
from something talk to somebody sketch
something out what are you going to
sketch well this is the thing is that we
sometimes they're the guide to good
testing is to understand the shape of
the thing is this a classifier is it a
value object
am i dealing with something that is
algorithmic am i dealing with something
that has a lifecycle oh it does have a
lifecycle life cycles most naturally
represented using certain state
notations so maybe that's what I sketch
ok so different kinds of things will
invite different frames of thinking and
you can use those to then structure your
tests and in this particular case we saw
that it is quite hierarchical the state
there is nesting and we can actually use
that to our advantage in how we tell the
story which gets us away from that
tedium it would sometimes experience of
when sometimes people say oh yeah we got
it we got a we got a test class for this
it's got a hundred methods classes 100
methods are not readable it doesn't
matter that you put the word test in
them they're still not readable the
readability has not changed and then
you've got names that run off the side
of the screen or maybe not because
sometimes people sit there we go oh it's
fine I've got a ready you know I've got
an IMAX screen that's it's good you know
that's great it's like yeah but I'm
still human it turns out and and
honestly the weather at the other end of
that name is different to the you know
whether it's start so there is this
notion actually let us use one of these
these ideas that we already know
factoring out common ality use of
hierarchy let's actually make that
visual okay so we take from a visual
formalism and we actually let the
indentation follow so there is code yes
there is code but oh and with is an
observation Nicholas Werth in the 1970s
when he was talking about structure
programming basically made the
observation algorithms post data
structures equals programs and I want to
take a little bit goes go a bit further
I want to take a broader view slightly
less reductionist structure plus
interpretation equals programs and it
turns out that you can't put all of it
in the code yes but some of it somewhere
else some of it will always exist in the
minds of those who developed it some of
it may or may not exist in an external
documentation but the idea that the test
should carry some of the weight here and
can carry some of the way in a
meaningful way that gives you both
feedback in execution the Reds and the
greens
now you actually have something to
interpret it's deeper as set telling you
something useful and constructive as
well as being a static description of
what you're expecting so I hope that's
been thought-provoking useful I'm around
all day so I won't take questions
because we've just hit the break but I'm
happy to take questions in the break and
throughout the day and of course
remember the party's in here so I we're
happy to take questions but the later in
the evening it gets the more flippant my
responses may be thank you very much